now here's the thing because a liliane
Richard you're about to be roaming
Juliet in West End stage yes but
previously prince charming and
Cinderella in the big Disney live-action
remake and Lily James as beautiful as
you looked I said well oh well it's
beautiful you are
it's a relative the the courses
Cinderella like that must be properly
painful because that isn't your shape
well it's no I mean it's drawn in with
yes very tight your shape is close to it
yeah yeah but you're very slim so yeah
very some good yeah but what happens
when you try to eat with that on I mean
I drank a lot cuz it's long long hours I
was trying to keep myself away I drank
quite a coke and so I was birthing a lot
in the cause it was revenge' lesson the
hard way
there was a couple of nights you did you
would over over eagerly eat and their
bake it was shut down the set for a
while well Lily's like oh god get it off
the ribs like here and it just can't
good owning lunch cuz he's the one that
has to bear the brunt of you know I
thought you looked fantastic but your
your dress was constraining but all the
Prince dramas costume was quite
constraining as well that's good too
yeah it was it was very constraining
anyways I'd not imagined it was a Disney
thing what it was it Disney thing and
it's kind of here we go yeah no um it's
Disney and I'm in skin-tight quite thin
quite edible trousers or maybe some
people would see leggings I've done my
teeth that way and and and they can be
very revealing so we've spent a couple
of days trying out different
trying and trying out different
jockstraps I feel just seductive even
seeing the study and a couple of these
trying these and then and then once in
is standing with you knowit's Sir
Kenneth bland and and the sandy Poulos
oscar-winning costume designer and
trying on these things never ends just
kind of looking at you to see what they
can and can't see under the layers and
then we we try down to the latest one
and which resume which was just
basically a corset for men it was really
really tired we tried to end it
yes oh this works mhmmm great and
chatting amongst themselves and then
they've turned away in and then sandy
turned to me and I was like tears
welling a night I'm going to be sick and
they had to run in it and take off and
and and that one didn't get used no but
but in the publicity like it's Lily's
hand they're teaching he's not teaching
me shorts there seems to be your like a
pregnant woman intervene okay there's
always something covering you there's no
armor dress or something not dressed I
did an episode of Batman once and Adam
West who played Batman told me that they
had to take certain pills because they
were wearing these tight Batman costumes
and because this was the 60s you
couldn't see an outline of a gentleman's
gentleman
what what were these pills of which you
speak no I don't want though he said at
me and he wrote a book and he said it
then they had they had these really
tight things on because if you look at
old episodes of Batman you can see that
they've just sort of flap yes or
terrible that's all for I don't know I
wouldn't know myself
zel writers because it's got like a
master bakers wrist I'll change your
call I said will you come to that' I
mean I'm a serious actress I